un voto contra el establecimiento el
izquierdista gustavo petro y el
populista de derecha rodolfo hernández
pasaron la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia
dos opciones que rompen con la política
tradicional del país
para la izquierda son unos resultados
históricos es la primera vez que uno de
esos candidatos obtiene el mayor
resultado en una jornada electoral
presidencial
petro se quedó con 40 32 por ciento de
los votos los partidos políticos aliados
al gobierno de educ
el presidente de duke
su proyecto político
ha sido derrotado se trató de un triunfo
incompleto los 85 millones de votos no
le alcanzaron para llegar directamente a
la casa de nariño y ahora deberá
enfrentarse al empresario y ex alcalde
de bucaramanga que confirmó la remontada
que marcaba en las últimas encuestas
hernández que durante su campaña logró
crear una imagen de outsider de la
política obtuvo 28,1 por ciento de los
votos hoy ganó el país que no quiere
seguir ni un solo día más con los mismos
y las mismas que nos han llevado a la
situación dolorosa o en que hoy estamos
poco después de conocerse los resultados
el candidato derecha y apoyado por los
partidos tradicionales federico
gutiérrez que obtuvo el 23 91 por ciento
de los votos aseguró que apoyará el
ingeniero pero expresar públicamente
que nosotros no queremos perder el país
y que no vamos a poner en riesgo el
futuro de colombia y por eso rodrigo y
yo
votaremos por rodolfo y por mar l en el
próximo 19 la opción del centro también
se hundió sergio fajardo se quedó con un
distante cuarto puesto con sólo 4% de
los votos muy lejano de su 23 3% de 2018
el caracara petro hernández se definirá
el 19 de junio en la segunda vuelta
presidencial